you wanted to be a director mm-hmm and
so this is interesting because you
directed the Barry pilot I did directed
I've directed the first three episodes
of the show yeah but I was was curious
with the pilots the first time you've
really directed something yeah the first
time I had ever been on set directing
anything and I was so immersed in
directing and and you know prepping and
working with the director photography
everything we got to the first day of
shooting and I completely forgot to do
all my acting homework I didn't
understand into my lines
I didn't know how I was gonna care it
play the character of Barry at all
I do you had given it no thought given
at zero thought because I was so like
I'm directing and I just sat down I just
started cutting my lines I was like you
know what you could say that what have
you said that yeah not your fault it's
the directors bellarius so you knew all
this I think we have we have a clip here
and you claim that in this clip this is
where you're having a talk with these
Chechen guys that want you to do a hit
any want me to do it really you had a
lot more lines in this scene I did and
if you watch that this is me
legitimately as I'm saying my lines I'm
going is this how I want the character
to sound right yeah so the Edit room and
decided I'll trim yes we'll just trim
this down to nothing but no yeah this is
me litter this is me saying the first
lines as the character on the first day
of shooting and I'm I mean trying to
figure out this is what I'm gonna look
deep into your eyes to see that you're
even beer fusion all right let's look at
this clip from Barry now there's a lot
of ways I can do this for you one of
them is I could stab him in the nut
that's something I did once and I'm very
comfortable doing it again
or not why forget about it who would
want this can't you just shoot him
yeah because be shot is very painful
have you ever been shot huh I have it's
like crazy painful anything is better
than stabbing guy in knots
I'll shoot what you do okay going on I
think he's going to shoot him you got
notes from one of the co-creators of
Game of Thrones David Benioff yeah he
saw the first few episodes of your show
and he had notes for you yeah which is
nice you you you know him you might yeah
yeah no well Alec Berg knows them I'm
just a huge fan of his and and yeah he
said oh it's great episode threes ends
pretty dark and I was like you made Game
of Thrones like baby bio we don't like
kill a baby in it or whatever there's no
like dragons or anything there's no
right to say that anybody forever yeah
he was like a little dark you know I
think he was SATA more like wow that was
dark it wasn't like a criticism he just
went wow and into darkness yeah yeah
have you not seen your show yeah
you